[Music]
welcome back to science click today the
electromagnetic field
imagine two people in the void of space
playing catch with a ball
when he throws the ball the first person
experiences a recoil because he passes
momentum onto the ball
similarly when she receives it the other
person absorbs the motion of the bull
and also experiences recoil
by throwing and catching the ball the
two individuals have repelled each other
they were motionless at first under now
in motion
if they continue to pass the ball their
speeds will increase each time and they
will move away from each other faster
and faster they behave as if they were
experiencing a force the action of the
bull can be viewed as a force of
repulsion
[Music]
in nature at the quantum scale this
phenomenon is at work between certain
particles such as electrons which
constantly exchange virtual photons
a virtual photon is a particle stemming
from the laws of quantum physics which
can appear out of nothing provided it
disappears fast enough such that we
cannot detect it
a virtual Photon has a certain energy
and the more energy it has the shorter
its lifetime
therefore the less energy a virtual
Photon has the greater the distance it
can travel
by exchanging virtual photons electrons
experience a repulsion a force that
pushes them away from each other like
the two people playing catch
this force is increasingly powerful as
the distance between electrons shortens
because the virtual photons then have
less distance to travel and can thus be
more energetic
many other particles exchange virtual
photons and their tendency to interact
in this way is called the electric
charge
[Music]
the electron has an electric charge of
-1e
e is the basic unit for electric charge
a particle will have a certain multiple
of this Elementary brick
some objects interact more than a single
electron we can imagine an object
containing two electrons and whose
electric charge would be -2e
moreover some particles like protons
interact with virtual photons in the
opposite way their electric charge is
positive the charge of the proton for
instance is Plus 1e
just like with two electrons two
positively charged particles repel each
other however a negative particle and a
positive particle attract each other
charges of the same sign repel each
other while opposite charges attract
to take into account all these
interactions we introduce the electric
field
we can conceive it as a sort of
imaginary fabric
if we place an electron in the field
which is negatively charged the field
turns blue
however if we place a proton which is
positively charged the field turns red
if we drop new particles they will
escape from the areas which have the
same color as them
a neutral particle without electric
charge doesn't feel anything and moves
in a straight line
a positive charge such as a proton will
be repelled by Red areas and attracted
by Blue areas
and a negative charge on the other hand
will be attracted by red and repelled by
Blue
let's illustrate the electric field with
several examples
here is the field created by two
electrons
we see that the central position between
the electrons is an equilibrium
if we place a particle there it would
remain motionless somewhat like a ball
between two Hills
now here is the field created by an
electron and the proton
the two particles attract each other as
the electric field forms a bridge from
one particle to the other
finally if we place a chain of electrons
on one side and a chain of protons on
the other side we can create a uniform
electric field in which a particle would
always feel the same Force
doing so we can make electrons move
along an electric wire and thus create
an electric current
at this point a disturbing phenomenon
comes into play
consider an electric wire consisting of
a long chain of protons and electrons
through which flows an electric current
which corresponds to the motion of
electrons inside the wire
imagine now that we leave an object a
certain distance away from The Wire
which carries a positive electric charge
according to what we saw earlier each
proton in The Wire repels the apple as
their charges are both positive
at the same time each electron attracts
the apple with the same intensity
overall if we add up all these forces
they compensate each other and the apple
does not experience any net force
it remains Motionless
let us now throw the Apple to the right
[Music]
strangely we now observe that it is
gradually repelled by The Wire
while it is not subject to an electric
force the Apple seems to be experiencing
a mysterious force that pushes it away
this new force is very peculiar it does
not appear when the apple is motionless
but only when it is moving
moreover it seems to depend on the
direction and the speed of the Apple
this mysterious Force which appears when
an electric charge moves around is
called the magnetic force
to understand its origin we will have to
review what special relativity teaches
us
before that though let's study the
situation not from an outside point of
view but rather as it is perceived by
the Apple in its own frame of reference
from this point of view it is not the
Apple which moves to the right it is the
wire that moves to the left
now according to special relativity the
faster an object moves the more its
length gets contracted in the direction
of motion
in this reference frame the protons in
The Wire are now in motion they will
thus get contracted along the direction
of the wire the protons come closer to
each other
conversely the electrons appear to be
moving more slowly because the entire
wire is now moving to the left
they therefore get slightly stretched
compared to the previous point of view
and move away from each other
overall when we add up the forces acting
on the Apple from this point of view
they no longer cancel out there are more
positive charges protons than negative
charges
therefore the wire exerts a repulsive
Force which pushes back the Apple
by considering special relativity we see
that the electric field of a charge gets
distorted when it starts moving
this phenomenon involves the appearance
of a new Force the magnetic force which
is in fact an electric force perceived
from a different reference frame
similarly to the electric field we can
summarize all these behaviors under
another field the magnetic field
when an electric charge moves it creates
a magnetic field around it which can be
represented as arrows revolving around
the direction of motion
the magnetic force is a consequence of
special relativity and the behavior of
the magnetic field is therefore rather
strange
in a magnetic field a stationary
particle does not feel any Force
on the other hand a moving particle
experiences a force whose strength
depends on how perpendicularly the
particle moves in relation to the
magnetic field
this Force tends to pull particles in
circular trajectories the size of which
depends on their Mass their speed the
intensity of the field and the electric
charge
although it is difficult to visualize we
can get some intuition of the magnetic
field by considering the following
experiment we wind a wire on itself to
form a long coil and we apply an
electric current to it
by moving inside the wire each electron
creates a small magnetic field around
itself
overall these small magnetic fields add
up and form a large-scale field which
loops around exiting at one end and
entering back through the other end
in this way the coil behaves like a
magnet an object with Magnetic North and
South Poles
we call this an electromagnet
as for electric charges poles of the
same type repel each other while
opposite poles attract
in the center of the coil the magnetic
field is somewhat uniform almost the
same everywhere aligned with the axis of
the coil
if we were to launch an electron and a
proton inside it the two particles would
follow circular trajectories because of
the field but in opposite directions
since the electron is negative whereas
the proton is positive
in general most magnets do not require
any electric current to operate
some naturally have a magnetic field we
call them permanent magnets
in essence Elementary particles like
electrons have a Quantum property called
spin
as a first approximation we can
interpret spin as a sort of rotation of
the particle on itself
as it rotates the particle generates an
electric current which as for the coil
generates a magnetic field
Elementary particles thus behave like
very small magnets and if we align them
in a material they can form magnetic
substances
[Music]
to conclude the electric and magnetic
fields are inseparable one is the origin
of the other and it is natural to unite
them under a single concept the
electromagnetic field
the electromagnetic field behaves and
evolves in a well-defined way which can
be summarized in four fundamental
principles
we call these Maxwell's equations
the first equation tells us that an
electric charge acts as a source for the
electric field
the second equation tells us that
Standalone magnetic charges cannot exist
objects which would only have a North
Pole without a South Pole or vice versa
a magnetic north pole always comes with
a South Pole and if we try to cut a
magnet in two we inevitably end up with
two smaller magnets with two poles each
the last two equations translate how the
electric and magnetic fields evolve with
respect to each other
the first of these two equations tells
us that a disturbance in the magnetic
field affects the electric field
if we push a magnet inside a coil of
wire the magnetic field changes which
disturbs the electric field and sets the
electrons in motion
in this way by shaking a magnet inside a
coil we can produce an electric current
this is called induction a change in
magnetic field can induce an electric
current running through a wire
this technique is widely used by wind
turbines nuclear power plants or even in
telephones to convert motion into an
electric signal
finally the fourth equation tells us
that an electric current or a change in
the electric field leads to a
disturbance of the magnetic field
this last equation is crucial because
with the previous one it brings about a
circularity a change in the electric
field disturbs the magnetic field and
this disturbance of the magnetic field
in turn disturbs the electric field
this alternation between the electric
and the magnetic fields allows
electromagnetic energy to propagate in
the form of waves which travel at the
speed of virtual photons we speak of
electromagnetic waves they include
microwaves x-rays infrared or even light
many fascinating experiments can be
explained by the laws of
electromagnetism
one of these concerns how we can slow
down gravity
to do this simply drop a magnet over a
coil of wire at first the magnet Falls
faster and faster because it undergoes
the attraction of the Earth but as it
approaches the coil its motion causes a
change in the magnetic field
this change in the magnetic field sets
the electrons within the wire in motion
the fall of the magnet generates an
electric current in the coil
a coil with an electric current running
through it generates a magnetic field
like a magnet this new magnetic field
slightly counteracts the motion of the
falling magnet and slows down its full
inside the coil the magnet Falls more
slowly as if less affected by gravity
[Music]
[Music]